-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
This is it.
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, today is the
first day of February.
That's right.
[ Cheers ]
You can tell it's almost
Groundhog Day
because Tom Brady
announced he's retiring again.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
This morning, Tom Brady posted
an emotional video announcing
his retirement from football.
If you haven't seen it yet,
here it is.
-Good morning, guys.
I'll get to the point
right away.
I'm retiring.
For good.
-Oh.
That's nice.
Don't worry.
Brady will be okay.
Based on the deserted landscape
behind him,
I think he landed a role
on "The Last of Us."
[ Laughter ]
That's what I think.
Yeah, everyone got emotional
watching the heartfelt message.
Even Bill Belichick's shirt
holes grew three sizes today.
[ Laughter ]
But what an amazing career.
Brady played for 23 seasons.
Yeah, he was around for --
[ Cheers ]
Yeah.
Amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was around for a long time.
Let's just say Brady
was the only active NFL player
to see "Top Gun" 1 and 2
in theaters.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Brady is done,
and in a related story,
tickets to next year's
Buccaneers game are now free.
[ Laughter ]
Some more big news today --
the FBI searched
President Biden's beach house
in Delaware
for classified documents.
First, they searched near
Biden's corvette,
now they're searching
his beach house.
I'm starting to think
Biden created this whole scandal
as a humblebrag.
[ Laughter ]
"Why don't you check
by my infinity pool?"
[ Laughter ]
"Maybe there's something behind
the Picasso, I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
After the FBI
completed the search,
a White House spokesman
announced the results.
-Today, in a planned,
consensual search
with the Justice Department,
they went through
the Rehoboth beach house,
and no classified marked
documents were found.
-Yeah. Apparently, Moby now
works for the White House.
[ Laughter ]
They didn't find any documents
at Biden's beach house,
but even more embarrassing,
they found a sign that said,
"Where my beaches at?"
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-That's kinda weird.
Speaking of Biden,
today the White House announced
that he will get his annual
physical on February 16th.
It's gonna be crazy
after Biden's colonoscopy
when the doctor says,
"There's no easy way
to tell you this, but we found
more classified documents."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
everyone's excited about this.
Today, Beyoncé announced
the Renaissance World Tour.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fans are pumped,
while Ticketmaster is like,
"F my L."
[ Laughter ]
Beyoncé made the announcement
around 9:00 a.m.
Yep, she basically gave
Tom Brady an hour
to trend on Twitter,
then, she was like,
"This is mine now."
[ Laughter ]
Some more entertainment news --
it was just announced that,
after 21 seasons,
Dr. Phil's daytime talk show
is coming to an end.
You know this morning
Dr. Phil's publicist was like,
"It'll definitely be the biggest
retirement news of the day."
[ Laughter ]
"F my L."
Yeah, today, Dr. Phil released
a really touching statement
about his retirement.
He said...
[ Laughter ]
Some more TV news --
the new season
of "The Bachelor" is underway.
But some people are complaining
that this year's Bachelor
is too boring.
-Yeah.
You think so?
Well, the producers have decided
to do something about it.
Watch this.
-The word is out.
This year's Bachelor
is just too boring.
America, we heard you
loud and clear.
So we sent Zach home,
and we're replacing him with...
-Tom [bleep] Brady!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look out, Bachelor nation,
'cause Tom B.
is on a permanent vacation!
This retiree is ready to party!
[ Air horn blares ]
He's DTF --
done throwing footballs!
And he wants one more ring!
I'm talking Neil Lane bling!
So, huddle up
in the Fantasy Suite
and get ready
to touchdown there!
Hut, hut, what?!
"The Bachelor" --
fall in love with the GOAT!
-[ Screaming ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Exciting.
That's not boring at all.
-That's exciting!
-That's what we want to see
right there!
That's good TV.
Some business news --
today, the C.E.O. of Peloton
said that the company
will start making money again
and is no longer
on the "brink of extinction."
[ Laughter ]
Brink of extinction?
Calm down.
You're a bike with an iPad.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Peloton's C.E.O.
thinks they'll start
making money in June.
Everyone's like, "That's great.
Wait. Is there gonna be
another pandemic in June?
What do you know that we --"
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
For nearly a week,
crews in Australia
have been searching
for a radioactive capsule
smaller than a penny
that fell off a truck,
and today, they finally found it
on a remote road.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
Well, now it's a remote road.
It used to be a city.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually where Tom Brady
shot that retirement video.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this --
apparently, due to a shrinking
U.S. cattle herd,
cheeseburgers and steaks
are about to get more expensive.
And now Americans are looking
for other types of meat.
And I don't want to say
it's bad,
but Punxsutawney Phil
is now "missing."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-Hey, I heard about a 6-year-old
in Michigan
who was playing
on his dad's phone
and accidentally ordered
a thousand dollars worth
of food on Grubhub.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he ordered
one cheeseburger.
-Oh, really?
[ Laughter ]
-With -- With an egg on it.
Tomorrow is Groundhog Day,
which, of course, means tonight
is Groundhog Day Eve,
so it's only appropriate
if I read that classic story
we all know and love.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
'Twas the night
before Groundhog Day,
and, oh, what a treat-a.
[ Laughter ]
-"Treat-a."
-What?
-Yep, this is page one.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, what a treat-a.
-Treat-a.
-Dry January was over.
So we housed
Skinnygirl margaritas.
On Fireball, on Jager,
on anything potent.
We'll get so wrecked,
we'll take advice from a rodent.
Phil climbs out of his hole
and sees such a crowd.
Then says, "I was sleeping.
Why the hell are you so loud?"
[ Laughter ]
The people wished for spring,
warmth, and good luck,
while Phil ignores a FaceTime
from Staten Island Chuck.
[ Laughter ]
Men in top hats gather round
as their future is read
while Phil prays Bill de Blasio
doesn't drop him on his head.
[ Laughter ]
The men watched Phil closely.
What news has he brought?
After they touch him,
they'll need rabies shots.
[ Laughter ]
If Phil sees no shadow,
soon we'll have spring.
They lift him up
like a fat hamster "Lion King."
They look at the ground,
"Is it light, is it shady?"
while Phil's thinking, "Man,
I gotta retire like Brady."
Shadow or not,
the townspeople cheer.
Merry Groundhog Day to all.
Now pass me a beer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen,
right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 21 pounds ♪
♪ Let's get down, y'all ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-What a show!
Thank you very much.
What a show
we have for you tonight.
He is a five-time
World Series champion
and a member of the baseball
Hall of Fame.
New York Yankee legend
Derek Jeter is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The man!
-The best.
-The best!
-Jetes!
-Jeter!
-My favorite.
-Lovely.
-Yeah, I was so lucky to see
most of his important,
big milestone games.
I used to go to the games all
the time with Lorne Michaels,
and we used to sit there.
And I'm behind --
You know, sometimes,
we'd end up on camera,
'cause the seats are right
behind home plate.
But I just never knew kind of
what to do with my hands.
So I would just
kind of get nervous.
And I'd be like,
"Come on, Derek."
I was rooting for him
all the time.
So, every time you watch these
highlight videos of Derek,
you could see one nerd
in the background going...
[ Laughter ]
-Waah!
-And, yeah, that's me, yeah.
But anyways,
Derek Jeter is here tonight.
I love that guy.
-The best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Speaking of love,
I love her new single.
It's called "You Only Love Me."
It is out right now.
And she stars in season two
of the animated series
"Kung Fu Panda:
The Dragon Knight,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Rita Ora is here!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're gonna talk to Rita Ora,
then she's performing
"You Only Love Me"
later in the show.
Rita Ora in the house.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The best.
Hey, guys, it is time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Polls ♪
-These are polls.
Polls are very popular.
-True, people love them.
-Yeah, people love them.
Adults love them,
kids love them.
-Everybody loves them --
grandpa, grandma.
-Grandpa loves them?
-No.
-He doesn't like them.
-Yeah.
-He likes the poles more
at the strip club.
[ Laughter ]
-I wish -- I --
I wish my grandma liked polls.
-Why?
What's the matter?
-Huh?
-Why doesn't your grandma
like polls?
She loves polls.
Every time I --
Every time I go
to your grandma's house,
it's like she goes --
she would read polls to me.
-Sorry.
I hate to interrupt you.
You didn't hear what happened?
-No.
-Last -- Last Christmas.
-Right.
-We're out at the house...
-Yeah.
-...having some eggnog,
stuff like that.
I think she was probably is
medicated or something.
-Well, she has a lot of meds,
sure, yeah.
-Yeah, but she was wearing her
wig and everything, it was cute,
to have her over there.
-Oh, she's funny.
-Never mind. I don't even
want to talk about it.
-What happened?
What happened?
-What?
-What happened?
-Well, it was Christmas Eve.
And I don't know,
she was stumbling home.
-Yeah?
-And, uh, my grandma
got run over by a reindeer.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Where?
-On the way to her house.
-On Christmas Eve?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
Did that shake your faith
in Christmas?
-No, no,
me and grandpa still believe.
[ Laughter ]
Well, here we go.
This is polls now.
-Polls, yeah.
-This first poll asks...
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's easily his favorite.
This next poll asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Hello."
-Next poll asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's true.
It's the only one.
That's the best.
That's the best one.
-Fantastic bowl.
-This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one asked...
Well, that's all the time we
have for "Tonight Show Polls."
When we come back,
we're playing "True Confessions"
with Derek Jeter and Rita Ora.
Come on back, everybody.